hi i'm ashley graham and this is my
glamour unfiltered
[Music]
what's still so frustrating about the
conversations that we're having
today that i was still having 20
years ago when i started was um how do
you feel confident
in your body how do you dress for your
body and
it's the label conversation it's all
about how i look and how i feel you know
just because i
am a size u.s 16 and just because i'm
over 200 pounds and
just because i am in lingerie a lot
doesn't mean that i
need to have this constant conversation
about
what it takes to feel so confident
within myself just because i'm a big
girl doesn't mean
that i need to have this constant
confidence conversation like
to me it's so mind-blowing like why are
we not asking thinner women what does it
take for you to be confident as well
because i think that
it's not just about the exterior
sometimes it's about the interior
labels labels labels labels labels
everybody wants to talk about
labels and it sucks because we live in a
generation where
there's a label smacked on literally
anything and anyone and i think that we
need to get over it
i don't want to be personally labeled
because of a number inside of my pant
i don't think that men are labeled based
off of a number inside
of their pant and this is just you know
from my own experience
something that i have found to be
um divisive in so many ways
so i think we get rid of the labels we
treat people
as as the way that they want to be
treated and
that's it sounds so simple but yet it is
so hard for some people to understand
i do a lot of prayer i do a lot of um
speaking out loud to myself
affirmations are a big deal for me and a
lot of times i record them into my phone
and i
repeat them over and over again so that
when i'm getting ready in the morning
it's not like i have to spend
an extra 10 minutes on affirmations i'm
actually listening to it my own voice on
my phone so it's like i'm programming
myself
you create the world that you want to
live in and it's very important
that you put the effort into
manifesting what it is you want and i
think that it's easy for people to say
the word manifest
and it's easy for word to say
affirmations but if you're not
putting in the work and you're not doing
a daily deed to create that world then
you're not
actually going to feel hopeful for the
future
everything changes when you have a child
i'm always thinking of creative ways
to to be better for my son and making
smart choices has been
very important i want my child to to
live in a in a beautiful clean world
it's the same
when you're speaking about the fashion
industry when you're talking about
sustainability you know it's it's all
about everybody doing their part
and putting one foot in front of the
other and making sure that
we're creating a huge impact to
create change
[Music]
self-doubt has been something that i
feel like everybody has had to deal with
in such a big way and i've had imposter
syndrome i've
also felt as though is what i'm doing
even making
an a change or you know am i making a
big enough effort and i think that
things that are supposed to change and
things that are supposed to stick
those are the things that sometimes take
a while and slow and steady wins the
race
[Music]
a good place i started when i wanted to
find resilience in myself and where i
did find it was when i first moved to
new york
and i wanted to quit i i had been
bombarded with an industry
that kept telling me you're not good
enough you're not
skinny enough you're not big enough i
wanted to to give up
i told my mom that's it i'm coming back
to nebraska and she told me no actually
your body is going to change someone's
life
[Music]
filters face tune the high-end photoshop
i hate it
i hate it so much because i think back
to
the younger me who if there was social
media around
when i was 15 years old i would
have been crying and i would have been
so upset
that i had so much cellulite and my
favorite celebrity didn't
there's a big confidence issue that's
happening now and i think a lot
of it has to do with photoshopping
filters
and and and morphing yourself into
something that you're definitely not
and i think that it's so important that
if you have
a platform that you talk about those
struggles that you had and that you
still have because there's somebody
who's going through that that you're
going to change their life by just
telling your story
one of the biggest experiences and aha
moments i had in
season two a pretty big deal was with
demi lovato
and she told me the word body positivity
is not one that
she can actually relate to what she can
relate to is body acceptance
i was like can you please explain she
said actually i can't get out of bed and
say like
thick thighs you are so beautiful she's
like because i don't feel that my thick
thighs
are so beautiful but what she can say is
that guys you are strong today and
you're getting me out of bed
thank you and so it's just those little
bit of shifts
in your language to not make it
a lie to yourself but to make it an
encouragement to yourself
to shift your thinking
the most important thing to remember
walking into
our new normal and walking out of a
pandemic and
you know maybe you're stepping into a
new body is to remember that you're not
alone
that your body is strong that your body
is your body if you don't have
body positivity within yourself maybe
think about it from body acceptance
and remember that this is your one body
that you've been given
treat it well speak to it kindly
and remember that the younger people
that are around you are watching and i
think for parents it's really important
for you to remember that
your children are watching how you treat
and talk to your body
and that's exactly how they're going to
treat and talk to their bodies
so just keep that in mind no pressure
[Music]